all right Tim Bailey has a question v
Tim Bailey um Neil what is your favorite
science fiction book TV series are
filled the correct answer is BBC's Red
Dwarf by the way that's what he wrote
but no what is yeah what's your favorite
sci-fi okay favorite science fiction for
TV has to be the original Star Trek
series yeah and because of it was
nothing it was like nothing that came
before yes there was science fiction
yeah this one but it was unrealistic
like but Rogers the difference was this
told stories that really should have
been told in real earth situations but
no one would have allowed that to happen
right because they were offensive they
were this or they they probed our our
odd social mores because social
statements were being right you could
finally have a race of purple people or
green hey evacuate why are you so mean
to the green Vivek exactly so you can
transpose it into space and have these
stories still be told Twilight Zone was
an equivalent landscape in which to
conduct the storytelling so I just see
that as a really important series I'll
also add that the Starship Enterprise by
my read of the history of this telling
of science fiction story was the first
ship of its kind to not be designed only
to get from A to B yeah it was designed
to live on and also to explore its
mission was simply as religion what
science was not a destination I don't
know any other ship for which that was
the case yeah in the history of the
telling the magna carta
since then we've had those the others
that just go hang out yes yes faces
cruise ships exactly yeah so so I would
say to Star Trek the original series and
love that and The Twilight Zone which
have a lot of space themes yeah that era
we were going to the moon yeah they
address them on movies I have to put a
deep impact when the asteroid hit and
hit the ocean rather than having good
aim like the asteroids did in Armageddon
yeah at the Eiffel Tower and one hit
yeah I am or whatever so this one hit
the ocean most of the earth's surface is
ocean that got a lot of it so much of
the physics right I let him go on stuff
that wasn't right like this story I
that's it
I recommend it's based on the you but
what's so that's the one you find most
scientifically accurate what I find most
enjoyable and I thoroughly enjoyed a
Carl Sagan story brought to film contact
know that it was an interesting
treatment of how humans would react to
information that we found species of
until the aliens more intelligent than
we are humans just freaked out and I
enjoyed watching the attempt to capture